all right hey what's going on it's bill
burr and it's time for a special episode
of the Monday morning podcast it's not
on Monday it's not on Thursday it's
coming out I guess what with Tuesday
Wednesday we're gonna put this out as
soon as we can I have a special guest
here you know I don't do a lot of guests
so if I bring somebody in they got to be
a heavy hitter that's right they got to
be a mover a shaker a shot-caller
we have the one and only Judd Apatow
here pleasure to be here John how are
you buddy I like to be or usually you're
all by yourself just talking to the wall
yes I am and usually you're in the midst
of producing which fascinates me I tried
to talk to you about this because I like
to think I'm kind of a busy man too how
you managed to have movies TV shows
stand-up special masterclass documentary
on Garry Shandling how the [ __ ] manager
keep like how big is the boat and the
war room it's all management technique
that's what you want to know I'll tell
you a good management technique the
staff of crashing a room right now
writing the fourth season third season
comes on in January but they're writing
the fourth season and I'm here with you
yes
that's managed so ah so how do you check
in with that how do I check that every
day did they send you a draft and you
just kind of keep it in bounds of where
it needs to be or at season four is it
sort of up and running well usually what
it is is Pete and I and also Judah
Miller and Oren who work on the show
we'll kick around a little bit what we
think the season might be right we bring
in writers for a month and we just kick
it around very openly like anything is
on the table and I'll pop in and out of
those meetings and and then there's
notes and I'll read the notes and then
sit in for half a day and then take a
day off and then pop back in and usually
that gives me some perspective because
you've been in those rooms there's a lot
of Chinese food there's a lot of
danishes you get tired lunch is huge
there's a lot of people talking about
things that have nothing to do with the
show for very long periods of time and
then at some point I'll sit with Pete
and we'll go through everything
right and go okay which ideas do we like
you know my favorite thing is is the
mental break you take in the writers
room it's like you're pitching your
pitching your pitching then you're fried
and like I always look around the room
and I'll just see someone hasn't pitched
a minute and they're just sort of
staring down at the ground for about 15
20 minutes and then they just come back
up like all right what if Frank did but
you literally you have to do it and what
I learned on efforts for family though
was I didn't realize how fried you get
yes in the writers room in like my
drinking went off the rails a little bit
it was one little scotch and then it
just became like three so last season
at what time of day though are you
having your scotch in the room oh not in
the room no it was when I got home when
I got home I would literally just you
know put on the fireplace turn it on now
because you don't light a fire anymore
you just turn it on and then I would
just sit there like yeah I was getting
to that [ __ ] it was just like I need
this at the end of the day so in season
three like I did this thing I go not
only may not drink in this season I'm
actually gonna try to do the impossible
which is drop weight and I was from
which I did how I packed a lunch like I
was a second grader so every day that
they would they would be going out now I
had like this quinoa bean thing that I
would always have and then just fruit
nuts you know it would be my snacks or
whatever because there's a reward you
want to reward yourself you know you get
to work whatever 9 10 o'clock and all
you think whole morning is I think at
12:30 the food's gonna land
oh yeah the food's gonna land then we
can stop talking about this show and
it's food and if everybody voted a place
that you [ __ ] hate yes it's just like
that is the longest day ever but if
you're going to like you know it's like
a Friday and they picked an awesome like
lunch place like that can literally yeah
better but I like that you are not in
charge of that because the only area I
will throw my weight around right is if
they say hey we're going to eat here
today I'm very comfortable going we are
not going there today daddy needs this
right now there's definitely a busy
there's also there's a generation gap
and that also goes with nutrition yeah
you know so there's people like my show
takes place in the seventies so that's
there's people that grew up in the
seventies and other people were born in
the 80s so they're there
more likely to go to something a little
more healthier than the old sort of John
Wayne people in the room like I'm not
eating that [ __ ] in some days there's a
little bit of a mutiny but it's not
about the writers from here I actually
they sent me which was really cool thank
you you guys sent me a link to the first
episode of season three of crashing with
the great Pete Holmes and just once
again it's like like watching that show
it's like I've lived this I've I don't
want to give away what the episode is
about but I mean and generally speaking
it's like Pete has now gotten to the
point where he actually has his own
place which is awesome and he's
mentoring a young man yes geppu kee from
The Daily Show who's on a daily show oh
okay yeah who's great and it's he
finally feels cocky enough to give
someone else advice yeah
and oh yeah you talk like he's in the
mix he's kind of feeling himself a
little bit and as always this business
will humble you so he ends up getting
humbled and it's like just a way the the
how you when he gets humbled I don't
want to say it is the way it's written
that he then lashes out at this person
that he kind of smooths stuff over with
and that's just like the worst
especially with the woman then you get
that whole you're enjoying this aren't
you you're enjoying that I mean I
literally had that fight with my wife
like two days ago
what was she enjoying that I lost my
temper yeah and then you know and then
she gets to you know like you know how
to deal is you know with women nothing
is off bounds but like with you you have
to stay within the lines or else you'll
never hear the end of it so you know she
you know you know she was driving the
car all over the place all over my life
letting me know who I was but you know
she was right about a lot of it and
that's the worst part is that they are
right about a lot of it no but they're
also wrong so I know this this whole
period now where women like they went
from nobody listening to them to now
everything that they say is spun with
gold is it's it's it's getting
ridiculous it's like we have to be okay
let's let's you know women alike guys a
lot of them are just full of [ __ ] you
know as are men so I mean that that's
the art of life is trying to figure out
who actually has the information that
you need which is why when I talk to you
how to you know manage a show you have
the goods with everything you got going
on here
well sometimes you know the thing about
it is that you do need someone who has
the perspective to judge ideas and how
things are going so there's a process of
generating maybe a thousand ideas for a
show but if you're burnt out from being
part of that generation that's hard for
you to pick what works yeah and so like
at girls I was very involved in the
writing but I wouldn't go to this set
because it was so well directed there
was no reason for me to be there the
footage always was great and Lina and
jenni were graded monitoring the
directors and directing themselves at
what point did you have confidence to be
like all right this thing is cruising
well I don't think I ever felt like it
was it was it was cruising but I had
confidence in if the script was good
they would shoot it great right and then
I could put all my energy into just
reading the scripts to give them a
person who could tell them if the
scripts worked right you know so they
were tired from shooting and writing and
and they're exhausted and I'm able to
have a little more energy to just read
and go on page four it's weird why they
say that right I'm not tracking and it's
that's hard to do when you're in the
thick of it and you're exhausted and so
there is a value to you know picking
where you're helpful and where you're
like you don't need me here I don't have
to sit and look at over the directors
shoulder you're nailing it let me save
that energy for write the writing part I
hate to admit this but I actually enjoy
being in the writers room oh yeah I was
like kicking and screaming thinking
about god I'm a comedian I'm free why
the [ __ ] am I going to go back into the
math class or whatever and I just say
this on days where it's working yes when
it's working and it's cruising and we're
getting good notes you know we always
get good notes but I mean positive notes
yeah from Netflix like we enjoyed this
but then on the days were like this does
it really there's too much of that and
then we go alright and then we try to
fix it and then it's just not working
those are the days where I feel like I'm
back in high school I'm just like it's
the clock broken like what are we doing
here so you're the teacher that's the
thing you know when you work on the show
and you're not the teacher like at the
Larry Sanders Show if we did a table
read and it wasn't working then suddenly
there is someone upset with you right
and you're ashamed that had the script
and then you're like how can I fix it
and and and there's almost a daddy or
mommy character that you're
disappointing if the show isn't working
or if the script isn't working there's a
lot of ways for it to be super unhealthy
but it is more fun you're right when
you're that person and you can treat
people well and you have your own strong
point of view it's not as painful yeah I
would say in my room at Mike prices he's
the captain of the ship so I'm the guy
that sort of chimes in and tries to like
I don't know keep it like certain things
tethered to reality if it starts getting
a little too like absurd but you know
you brought up Garry Shandling who like
you know anybody who's even remotely in
the comedy just I mean that guy's like
on the Mount Rushmore there and I just
remember you know I watched you know you
know this is the theme the Gary show I
watched his first one I watched
everything I used to watch this Tonight
Show sets I just always just thought the
guy he just always it was funny when
even like when I was in junior high as
like in seventh grade I knew that his
stuff was just funnier yeah it was this
is like a different level like this guy
is better than all of these other guys
and I was wondering like what was that
like you know because I really I sent an
email about that like I thought the
Garry Shandling documentary that you did
was that's my favorite thing you've done
and I have thanked you 40 year old
virgin all this stuff but what was that
like because you were friends with
somebody sure like that you know myself
I've lost a couple of friends and I know
that certain things it just gets like
really emotional what was it but I never
delved into their life to the level that
you did with with Gary who was like a
friend and a mentor to you like what was
that process like like how long did it
take you to to you know because that was
on par with like did you see that
Eagles documentary I love that it was
like three hours long and if Ellie was
20 minutes yeah and it got through like
a cross-country flight watching that I
felt like the Garry Shandling duck was
like that what was that like it was like
the Eagles dock if if Gary wasn't on
coke yeah well you know it's funny cuz
now that it's over and I've been you
know I finished it six or eight months
ago something like that looking back
it's almost like a fever dream that I
even
right because he died I was really
depressed and it threw me more than I
thought because he was a constant
presence of support and I didn't realize
what an important beam he was in
everything and and and I thought I think
there's just a lesson that he wants to
teach everybody and I'll tell you a
story that they kind of launched the
documentary is that I went to Gary's
cremation and so Gary's cremation was
very moist I mean people don't go to
cremations you're not supposed to go yes
no wait you saw Mike sliding the body in
well kind of it's Jesus Judd basically
how did you get tickets to that I only
tell this story because I think it's it
it's helpful to people in their own
lives is that a you know a friend put
together a very small service so if you
can imagine there's only like eight
people there and in an oven basically
and and like four Buddhist monks right
so that takes the edge off a little bit
like they're here they're not freaking
out yeah they could they were fine with
it that's their whole religion okay so
we go to this place and it's in the
valley and it's not that far from these
offices and it's you know a crematorium
is it part of a strip mall there's like
ramen noodles get your tax done why
should your friend get burned even worse
it's deeper in the valley where it's
just next to a place that like you know
makes glass bowls or something house in
an industrial area so we go there it's
clear no one's ever had a service in
this space this isn't what people do so
there's no like room to do it we're
literally in like the lobby of a place
that looks like a sham business of some
someplace right and like what they're
selling in the lobby there's literally
just like one desk and empty space and
did you make sure it was Gary underneath
be sure the crash-test dummy that'll be
50 grand like what they were selling
there they have these little these
little pamphlets where you could take
some of the ashes of your beloved and
have them put into like a little glass
figurine you could put on your table or
like something you would wear Oh God let
it go it's okay gone gone so we go we go
to this this place and we go into this
little room and again it's like it
couldn't be ratty er really and they
have a service which is very sweet and
it's beautiful and and moving and all
the ideas of Buddhism and and and then
they take us in this room now the room
with the crematorium it's like the
kitchen to a restaurant it's just like a
big room with the cement floor and like
four or five so then they did a little
service they hit some little [ __ ]
gongs or something like what happened
yeah they're just they did Buddhist
prayers and they talked about Kerry's
life and and and what life is about you
know you you know you live you die you
you learn the lessons that you can you
try to be as loving and kind as you can
hopefully you you know you grew and it
was very sweet actually sounds cool now
do they believe in a heaven and hell
Buddhist people here's it my issue is I
did get deeper and deeper into it it had
to reincarnation I I believe and I
always get lost when things get too
magical I like something that's clear
like life is about being kind and that's
it like that's that's as far as I
usually can get I guess the scriptwriter
in you they think you need it to land
magical in anyway as soon as someone's
reborn or goes to heaven or hell I'm
lost I have trouble now I'm not a
hundred percent closed but I'm pretty
close but I do I can get interested in
ideas that are about how can we you know
let go of our egos and be kind that's
all I need okay so we have the service
and it's and it's they bring you to the
other movie and then we go on the other
and it's literally you know a table with
a cardboard coffin and and they say some
more prayers and then at some point they
open up an oven which looks like almost
like a dishwasher and a restaurant and
they roll it in flames already going or
do they turn it on after they close the
door there's a pilot light and Viking
stone what am i sticking it's literally
not that far from a pizza oven okay okay
and you know they put the cardboard
coffin in then they close close it
almost like if a dishwasher in a
restaurant and then they asked who wants
to push the button oh Jesus
and you know they're saying do they have
a bunch of fake buttons like a firing
squad like somebody gets blanks and one
guy really blows his brains out yeah no
one wants to know who yeah you don't
want to carry that and then a friend of
Gary's you know push the button and then
suddenly you're here and fire up you
know it's getting hotter than your
normal pizza oven and the room gets hot
and then it's like you smell something
burning like it's like you know if it
was like a fire at your neighbor's house
and suddenly like your chest hurts a
little bit then you realize it's Gary
there's no there's no vent I guess I
guess I maybe it was a place that needed
more ventilation no I mean there is a
vent it's not like overpowering like the
room is all filled with smoke but you
know do you realize like some day if you
go on a fast to get rid of toxins in
your body part of that is Gary Shandling
exactly and that would sadden me but but
that's what was crazy about it so now I
love Gary so much I will never go in a
fast and pray breathe that Wow
and so so I'm you know watching this
crying my eyes are just bawling it's as
intense as anything I've ever
experienced yeah this is pretty heavy
and I'm feeling it in my chest and I'm
aware like that's Gary we're breathing
in Gary and at first it you know part of
me it made me laugh like yeah because
this is super creepy dude you know it's
creepy it's kind of weirdly like the
Gary always would make the joke like I'm
inside you you know like there's like a
sexual joke to be made there right and
then I just thought God Gary would find
us so funny all of us sitting here
crying watching them cremate his body he
would think that this was fantastic like
me here bawling my eyes out Gary would
look and just go like that's right
that's what it is that's what it is and
and I thought in that moment this is a
lesson like having to look at that will
change your life having to be at the
crematorium about you know what's
important what do we care about how do
we treat people what do you want to do
with your life and I thought Gary wanted
me here he wanted me to go through this
hell and this freaking you know oh it's
just part of his like no he didn't ask
for it but I didn't like a spiritual
level I thought this is it Gary wants me
to learn every freaking lesson to the
point of his incineration he wants me to
look it in the eye and take from it
whatever I can take to be a better
person and I think in that moment was
you know this seed of how do I tell
other people this lesson because I think
in Gary's life he was trying to figure
out how to talk about this stuff and you
know it's very hard in comedy to do it
without seeming really corny or weird
you know as soon as people start talking
about their spirituality in a sincere
way we're all like shut the [ __ ] up and
it feels you got to be like interviewed
by Oprah and she has to bring it out of
you and act like well she asked me the
exact the only waited that's the only
cool way to do it I mean and I had so
many friends that tried to and they
always seemed odd and I think Gary when
he did comedians in cars getting coffee
was the first time he found a way to be
really funny but talk about some things
that he believed in and I think that was
his goal near the end of his life he's
trying to figure out how to reinvent how
he did stand-up and get some of these
ideas in and he hadn't quite cracked it
he was really into silence he loved not
getting a laugh he loved putting people
through weird silences and he would say
to the crowd that that's where it all is
it's all in that silence right and he
didn't have a joke
didn't even know what to do with it he
just knew when the room went dead
contemplating is what they're doing the
contemplation of what was just said and
so when I was working on his memorial
service I cut together four or five
little mini docks about Gary and when I
was making them I thought oh yeah
there's a whole movie about Gary about
what he believed in and and that's how
it started well it's incredible and it
just came out on blu-ray people out
there still have the blu-ray players you
know I still have a I have a DVD VCR
player but my TV's too advanced and I
can't hook it up to that so if anybody
knows that there's some sort of adapter
or some other thing I can do to try to
make that work I would appreciate it but
uh yeah because you know III you know
finally became a parent so I had to get
my affairs in order
yeah you know you know it's a guy you
got to make sure everybody's gonna be
okay
you got the will like to the point like
I gave I hooked my wife up so much like
she has motive like if I die suddenly
I've had that the conversation with my
wife and the insurance agent have you
done this conversation yet well you sit
with an insurance agent about life
insurance anything well if Judd lives to
this age you get this if he if he lives
at this age you get that and it's
gambling you're gambling on me dying
you're patting against yourself like
haha I died before you thought I was
gonna now you got to give him all this
money and my wife wouldn't buy the extra
insurance because she said I feel really
weird you know having any you know
handicap in her death and she was deeply
upset at the conversation that was like
six or seven years ago and and just the
other day she's like maybe we should get
that insurance yeah that's what happens
after well I you know once you have kids
and stuff but like I you know I went
with the cremation thing I think it's so
stupid to stick yourself in the box and
then they like you're that important
that there's got to be like a head so I
guess it's for the living people have
someplace to go but I think now just
with the world population I mean the
graveyards at some point I mean I don't
know if they're going to dig deeper
you're gonna be underneath somebody else
but I've had a lot of people go well
what if you still feel stuff it's just
like well then let's get it over with
which friend of yours think
you still feel stuff a lot of people are
afraid of death it's just stuff do you
know something I don't even know cuz i
short term memory is bad but a lot of
people say that about the about like you
know if you get cremated what if you
still feel stuff it's like well I'd
rather just get it over with in a minute
I guess I die again somehow in that
minute but uh rather than laying there
waiting for the worms to slowly work
their [ __ ] way in burn it this toss
it out of an airplane I want to go I
want to I I wish I don't just probably
isn't legal in this country but I want
to do it like the Viking way like a
little ship sure yeah send me out there
gives people shoot some flaming arrows
you know give it to make a little
contest it's like burn it on the Ganges
yeah it's like a clay pigeon a type of
thing but anyways what else we got we
got a benefit coming up to that you're
doing at the Gramercy for the Ronald
McDonald House is one of the great
charities out they can go to Judd Apatow
calm slash tour that's January 15th
Graham is at Gramercy Theatre yeah in
New York and it's pede and John Mulaney
p-hound and Regina Spektor and some cast
members from from crashing oh yeah
djibouti and Jamie Lee and and me and
yeah it's for the Ronald McDonald House
which is Ana monster lineup John Mulaney
I mean that guy's just he's just in New
York he's genius guy so all right what
else do what else we can we can we
discuss it we promoted we've promoted it
was the hallway you master class I have
a master yeah in the presence of them
how do you get how do you like get does
somebody approach you with like with
something like that like you want to go
like I could teach a master class on how
not to read out loud yeah out of the
[ __ ] things up how to make your wife mad
at you for three days in a row sure I
have that mastered what was what was
your master class well I did it because
my friend Jay Roach who directed Austin
Powers he directed my master class so
it's basically several days of talking
to Jay Roach who's asking me quite
there's no crowd or anything like that
it's like a TED talk or anything no it's
just and they just added it added it up
and
and I think it came out really well you
know the thing you probably know because
you've worked with a lot of people and
staffs it's so much of it is just
inspiring people to work hard people are
so damn lazy like people just don't put
in the effort at all I told I told
someone that the other day I was like
look you gotta have a certain level of
talent but what separates people is just
like I mean the people who have like
that work ethic and it's almost got to
be like and people in this business are
kind of workaholics I've learned that
with deficit family so many people hey
want to go through it again I was like
oh yeah yeah like these people are
[ __ ] insane like they don't want to
go home but the people that I saw like
just really really really work I don't
want to name any names because then if I
don't name names people saying what he's
saying I'm [ __ ] lazy but I just I saw
a lot of people that weren't the guy
yeah but work their way like into being
the guy but like you know with you it's
got to feel good when somebody comes and
asked you to teach a master class I mean
you certainly have the body of work and
all the stuff that you've done it
because that's I think the last three
times I've talked to you that is what
I've asked you how do you and my
delegation of that [ __ ] cuz I still want
to be a comedian and still you know and
still being good is you have to be out
there doing it but if how do i you know
but I also love doing the show and then
I also got to be a dad like how do you
how to [ __ ] do you balance all this so
is some of that in in there the math
yeah absolutely and I think that like a
lot of it is you know that you're just
pushing pushing balls forward so you may
be on the road doing stand-up and you
have a great idea for a movie and it's
just making sure in some consistent way
you're pushing it forward and making
progress now you might finish it in
three months you might finish it in
three years but if you have four or five
things going at the same time that's
really what it is is you know I might
get up in the morning and go from the
moment I get up to lunch I'm gonna work
with Pete and in the afternoon I'm doing
a movie Pete Davidson I'm gonna rewrite
Pete Davidson and then you better get
burned out do you get frustrated the
illusion attempt you seem like a chill
guy it's just like is this how you are
like you behind the scenes you one of
those guys throwing laptops like it
doesn't
we're gonna stay here all night where I
only get crazy on two issues what like
two or three issues one is if the food
order is wrong I just I can't handle it
like if they don't bring the salsa with
the burrito like I so reward myself with
that that could go viral that could go
bad
your your your now that's okay that's
that's diad that's understandable
my biggest moments of shame where I go
you really lost it or mainly around food
but the areas where I get crazy one is I
used to people who tell me I couldn't
have my casting and that would always
drive me crazy if I said you know who
the star of the show should be it should
be Jason Segel and then Foxx would go no
that's where my head would explode and
where would you explode on the phone to
them in your car to your windshield
every see every scenario I mean I'd be
screaming I did tears I would be
threatening I'd have agents calling and
I never won as a result it took me years
to realize oh all my emotional reactions
have never won me the fight and then
when I stopped behaving that way I
started winning more of those debates
but I would get so upset because to me
the worst thing in the world is if you
know you have an edit of a movie and
someone forces you to change it and
you've ruined your own movie due to
something does that happen
well it I that's the one area I just
can't allow to happen now I have had
things change in the past that I look
back at more so you know a couple of
decades ago where I did give in and now
even right now I thought about that
movie I'm like why did we cut that scene
and I told us to cut that scene and
there was a scene in and did you fail -
because you were young and just trying
to get your foot in the door everybody
always says that thing you know you just
you got to let him get him get you the
first time and then the next time you'll
be able to write your own ticket now do
do you subscribe to that well I think
it's true only in the sense that you
can't win you just don't have the power
right so we made this movie heavyweights
and Paul Feig was in it and Stiller
played the bad guy was a summer camp for
fat kids and it was a
it was a Disney movie and then when we
finished it and see real directed and
wrote it with me it was just a little
darker than any Disney movie you've ever
seen and it ended with was always a
funny yeah I was it was funny and not in
the way that a lot of those movies are
yeah I just Diller at the end of the
movie he's lost his mind he's the owner
of this fat camp but he's like this like
demented Tony Robbins guy and he's got a
bow and arrow and he's like threatening
to kill all the children and Disney said
you know you really can't have him like
point pointing bow and arrows from Jill
at children we're like three feet away
right and so we had to riad it the
sequence that's the kind of stuff I'll
wake up at 2:00 in the morning go wide
we cut out the goddamn bow and arrow
sequence still eats that yeah yeah and I
might have five of those and so that's
where I can know what point in your
career where you like all right all
right Jed screaming at people and
they're flipping out during these
moments isn't working yeah like how did
you cuz I am like my big Achilles heel
is is it's not anybody it's funny it's
not at work I don't flip out in comedy
clubs I don't I've never flipped out at
Ephesus Pamela I've raised my voice of
akiza's cry wait how do we [ __ ] about
but I never like got to the point of
like you know
never had a big you know storm out
[ __ ] fill and [ __ ] never had one of
those but like it's more like at home I
you know I just like flip out about just
stupid [ __ ] like I [ __ ] suck at these
iPhones in laptops I get so far I'm so
frustrated because I don't like them
technology doesn't fascinate me it's not
something I'm interested in it's wrong
it's ruined the world so Edie
you know many ways it has it in other
ways it hasn't metasomatic medically
it's nice when you're kids older and
they don't look up at you for hours
you'll go they brew in the world yes oh
yeah that aspect of it but I definitely
like I just don't like how yesterday I
knew how to use this device and then now
I don't now I have to go through this
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's just every time
you know you move three feet ahead they
knock you back with the new you know
updated system and then you can't you
can't opt out of not updating it because
you should be able to keep your phone
for years and there's just like now
we're going to fill up this [ __ ]
phone and you have to bring it in and
then we're gonna take everything off it
and sell to some kid in the Philippines
you just feel like you just part of this
thing and like that's the type of [ __ ]
like I'm trying to you know didn't and
I'm failing miserably at it but explain
the flip out is it alone like throwing
it against the wall are you yelling at
another person like what does it turn
into I just literally like my wife will
be just totally chillin watching TV and
then I don't know where I'll just yeah
you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] I flip out like
that and like what I don't know cuz I
grew up with that I didn't understand
what it was doing to her as far as just
really just having her be on edge and uh
yeah so I mean how did she tell you not
to do it what's her approach to telling
you to chill out oh man she's just
straightforward she's straightforward
she said she said some I'm not gonna you
know this is too intimate of detail but
she said some [ __ ] to me like two days
ago that I will never forget and I was
like wow is everything because your she
knows you're about to do it in front of
a child that understands it so when
they're little they're babies and you
can go in the other room but at some
point you just spend so much time with
your kid that they will absorb it yeah
and then you go so I like the way I move
in the world cuz I think my kids gonna
copy it yeah so fortunately I am really
on my best behavior for the most part
around my kid she's seen me flip out a
few times but I quickly try to turn in
and do a joke but it's something yeah I
got to go to therapy dude because I I
don't want to because she's getting to
the point now where she's repeating
stuff and I just don't I don't wanna
this is the deal she's not gonna be like
me I already know she's not gonna be
like me
it is far in a good way so I mean that's
kind of what does that say about me like
my job is a dad to this to make my treat
not like me
well the way you're half me but I don't
want you to be me at all I want you to
be like your mom well they don't really
have the damage of us you know so that's
the thing I've noticed is you know my
kids are hilarious but they're neurotic
kids too but they didn't go through some
of the intense things that I went
through that really built how my mind
works
but but I'm sure they have their own
their own men know I bet there's a whole
new level of [ __ ] with just like social
media didn't exist so like what I liked
about my childhood was once school was
over the ass-kicking was over whatever
thing humiliation I could go home it was
fine it didn't continue but Mike Douglas
show was on he'd watch it yeah he'd heal
yes yes there wasn't this think tank of
kids trying to you know getting all
online and pile on you in the [ __ ] that
they deal with so and they know when
they're being excluded so the biggest
issue is because of Instagram you're
aware what you've been invited to so
when people are hanging out you're like
oh they didn't want me at this thing
when I was a kid I was excluded by
everybody I had one or two really good
friends but basically if I thought about
it if I think about it now I was
excluded from every possible social
thing that was happened went past at the
club but I but I didn't know it you know
I just would go home every day and just
watch the Dinah Shore show and be fine
and wait for my friends to get back from
football but now the kids know like oh
those three girls went to the mall oh
those two are hanging out at this
concert and they feel bad no and then
they take a picture which is not an
accurate depiction of what it's like
it's like it's like they're selling the
movie of like their life or anything so
that's the that's the thing I get
nervous with and that's been you know a
source of you know back and forth me and
my wife is like I don't like her
watching TV and all of this [ __ ] and I
don't like your eating junk food and you
know and she has more of like like she
wants a little bit TV occasionally has
McDonald's and it's like it's alright
but you know I mean this is the fight
you have because yeah you when you're
married you're instantly deciding how
much do I care about each thing and what
how far I want to push my wife like in
knocked up one of the scenes that I like
but it's a it's a intense scene is
Leslie sitting there and she's looking
at a website that tells her where sexual
predators live in the neighborhood ah
and Paul comes in and he just keeps
making jokes about it
and she's really freaked out like do you
know there's a guy like three fish
streets over and
all keeps making jokes yank well let's
not go to his house on Halloween and
then finally she's like that's what I
would know did she finally says like
sometimes I just want to rip your
[ __ ] head off because you're so
[ __ ] stupid and that really is what
marriage is about is there there are
issues that you care about like how much
McDonald's should the kitty now when I
was a kid I swear to God I had a
McDonald's I'm not kidding you six times
a week and I loved it
I ate it my mom had no issue taking me
there every single time we cigars left
the family like that's fine dining
[Laughter]
we had a big family who's five
cheeseburgers five small fries five
chocolate shakes two Big Macs two large
fries two cokes that was the order for
years and it was awesome every time yeah
yeah it was it was a nice beat jealousy
when I got older because I kept getting
a cheeseburger and I was big enough to
get a quarter pounder with cheese but I
was afraid to ask as you get [ __ ] and I
just we'd looking at there's only like
half way through it with their little
mouths trying to eat it and I didn't
wolf to mine down but yeah I remember
what I used to when I was really young
and I lived in a North Shore of Boston I
remember there was a McDonald's there
was this train track that was right by
and you would throw some of your french
fries to the seagulls yeah and you get
to see a train go by and you'd be
sitting outside and it was like some of
my fondest memories as a kid and you
know yeah there was no yeah you know
they were roughly the same age so it's
just all you know peanut butter and
fluff and all you know about it I know
when did you even realize McDonald's was
bad and what like how old are you when
you're like I guess I shouldn't eat this
well you knew fast food was bet but you
didn't know to the point like I make
McDonald's remember a few years ago they
had a bolt in a bullet board out a
billboard just came out it's like now
with a hundred percent beef which is
obviously well what the [ __ ] was it
before the page do you watch that movie
founder Michael Keaton oh you got to
watch that Michael Keaton's amazing in
that movie and it's such a it's such a
well done movie about like all of that
type of stuff so but then you know your
wife says I want to give the good son
McConnell to be like I think it might be
awful now
I have the poisoned I have the reverse
with my wife well used to be poison I
think now it's more like it's a little
more healthy right now it might be just
nothing
no positive anything but my my wife
early in our relationship when I would
get McDonald's would look at me like
what's wrong with you are you an adult
like you eat this food
she was so disgusted she shamed me to
such an extent that I don't even sneak
out and get it like she she programmed
me to be disgusted by the thing that
made me so happy
yeah my thing was when I was gonna be
healthy I went to Wendy's because Wendy
seemed like it was actually burger me
yeah probably wasn't either no it
probably was well dude I got to tell you
man it would it's such a thrill to have
someone like you come on on the show and
like and I really appreciate the advice
both on this and on off that you've
given me as far as like how to you know
you know keep it all kind of going
without without screwing it up and I'm
definitely check out that master class
of you and everybody check out January
15th at the Gramercy I'm what you want
to say Hotel Gramercy Theater I mean
John Mulaney Pete Holmes Judd Apatow for
the Ronald McDonald House is going to be
go to Judd Apatow calm slash tour once
again season three of crashing with the
great Pete Holmes January ingenuine
January Garry Shandling documentary is
on blu-ray and it's masterclass calm we
can watch just I guess imagine search
Judd Apatow and Pete Holmes news special
airs I think on the 15th which is he's
got a great new stand-up what's it
called it's called dirty clean dirty
clean and where it where can they see
that'll be on HBO on HBO I love it our
that's why why wouldn't it be a nice
feel he's in business with them alright
Jeff thank you so much for coming in and
everybody thank you for listening and
check out Judd Apatow January 15th
Gramercy Theater alright buddy thank you
thanks buddy